Speaker 1: Second piece of hugely positive news
and I'm not. You know what, before you even get
into this, let me go ahead and say, because
this is positive news all over social media,
people are glad about it, but saying, go
further and I'm going to talk about that. But
the piece of positive news
that I want to talk about now
is that the Biden administration announced
on Wednesday they were going to extend.
The student loan debt repayment deadline, meaning
instead of payments resuming on February 1st,
they are now set to resume on May 1st. They have
kicked it back 90 days, giving people more time,
I guess, to make adjustments. Whatever it is,
those three months mean the world to people
suffering under the burden of student loan
debt. And this wouldn't have happened. And
this is really the positive part of the story.
This wouldn't have happened without the push
from the public for the administration to do
this. That's the real positive part of this story,
that the activism work, much like actually
with the COVID tests in a week and a half ago,
Jen Psaki kind of laughed it off during a press
conference of What are we supposed to send a test
to everybody, you know, give it to them for free
and then after pushback to like, OK, we're we're
actually we are going to do that same thing with
this student loan repayment. People have been
pushing them, warning them. Even economists
have been warning them, you're about to deal
a major blow to the economy, taking out roughly
$85 billion from it when these payments restart.
Is that where you want to be in an election year?
Tanking your own economy, putting hardship on your
voters and the administration says, OK, we're
going to kick the can down the road 90 days.
So now it comes to the other
part of it, right? Cancelation,
full blown, absolute cancelation. And of course,
that is what a lot of people are pushing for.
To be honest, that is what I'm pushing for. That
is what I want to see happen in this country.
That's what needs to happen. Yes, I understand
all the arguments on the other side, you took
out the loans you're responsible for repaying and
what do we do next? Repay it, pay off your house.
Well, yeah, you want to get people into
homes, you want to get them off the streets.
You want to give them the opportunity
for a real chance at a better life.
Yeah, you could. You should. So I am all
for 100 percent full blown student loan debt
cancelation short of that, I'm in favor
of Biden keeping his campaign promise,
which is to pay off $10000 of everybody's
loans. He did make that promise.
It's still on his Twitter. You can go and see it
yourself. He said he would do that. And of course,
we can talk about the economic impacts of
that which, you know, some people, that's
the only thing that matters. So I went through
compile these statistics, looked at some old
studies from this year earlier this year. Here's
what we have right now. As of today, we have
one point five seven trillion dollars in student
loan debt held by more than 40 million borrowers.
The Levy Economic Institute of Bard College used
data from 2016, and they found that cancelation of
the outstanding student loan debt would translate
to an increase of 86 billion to $108 billion
on average per year to our gross domestic
product here in the United States.
Information from just a couple of
months ago. This is actually from
the Federal Reserve says that those payments
are averaging two hundred to $300 per month.
That's the average some people
pay less. Some people pay more.
But that's what we're looking at. So a full
cancelation, not just 10000, although 10000, would
cancel debt for millions of people. You're talking
about giving them an extra two to $300 per month,
which is what they've had during the pandemic. For
a lot of people, that's like an extra paycheck.
And do you know what people do with that money?
Well, we know because the analysis also came out
this week, along with the child tax credit,
they're using it to pay off other debts. Some
people are actually able to put some of it in
savings. They're using it to pay medical bills.
They're using it to pay housing expenses. They're
using it to buy food. They're using it on car
repairs, which is something that a lot of people
tend to overlook as a major factor. You know, when
we talk about those studies that show that people
can't afford an emergency of $700 or more, a lot
of those emergencies either involve in a mere and
immediate health crisis or an automobile crisis.
Car repairs are not cheap. And the cost of all
of those continue to go up each and every year,
and that becomes a major factor that takes
away somebody's ability to get to and from work
to take their kids to and from
school or daycare or whatever it is.
So that is a major problem. So two
to three hundred dollars a month.
If we had full student loan debt, forgiveness
would absolutely be life changing for these
individuals. And we have seen that since March
of 2020, when these payments were first paused.
So I applaud the administration for listening
to the public and pushing this 90 days back.
Personally, I want it all canceled.
Economically, it should be all canceled.
Zero it out. Change people's lives for the
better. And of course, the other side of that,
that is certainly would certainly help
Democrats politically in the midterms. Look,
we got to take a quick break. I'm Farron Cousins
sitting in for David Pakman. You can find me all
over social media at fair and balanced. We'll be
right back with more of the David Pakman show.